[Music]
stealing me in
is blackjack your game it's not so much
my game as it seemed my kind of place
I'll stay you sure you don't want to try
for more well when I see something I
like I know how to hang on to it
interesting philosophy
well can you tell me about that mug club
I'm just a girl looking for a good time
hit me are you sure that's what you want
oh I'm sure positive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the ancient art of kata we've
been practicing that for the last month
because to learn about cultures is to
appreciate cultures we have a huge show
for you tonight producing with me in
video studio as always as Jared who is
not gay follow him on Twitter at not gay
Jared me a desk router with your
comments conclusions not the photo shops
I fulfill my league obligations croghan
conclusions were good I'm still no good
to come out well none of us are gonna
come you know who's great at kata who
people who can't fight Morgan Jr yes I
wish people could see all your dance
moves in the intro not just a little
here and there
no that's beautiful its beauty its
strategic you need to pepper it in there
a huge show big big show we had a return
to but he's been traveling Europe all
that New York Dean Cain and then of
course Blair White too many people have
been asking for that for a while I I
hope it's Pleasant I acted am kind of a
fan of Blair and some of the content
that Blair puts out so we've had
differences in the past but that's what
louder with Crowder is for that and
horrible jokes also we'll be talking
about Vox sanctuary cities that's pretty
big right now it's obviously in the news
and Vox released a video I had a lot
I've had a lot of requests this weeks
and hanging you get into the sanctuary
city thing I don't exactly understand
what this is so we'll talk about that
but letting this off the reviews for
Bill Nyes series we talked about earlier
this week are in Bill Nyes series on
Netflix panned by critics it's been
plagued by low ratings and it seems like
it's going to be canceled bill Nyes
allegedly been returning or planning on
returning to its previous day job of not
science
poor poor guy you see this dripping
hairs in hot water because she compared
the illegal immigrants to slaves and
Jews it's one of those things when
you're thinking well how do you write
calm it she already went to slavery and
Jews and awesome compares it to slavery
you're like oh and someone compared this
to Jews in the Holocaust because it's it
were taking it more extreme she just
snatched up all the comedy she'll attend
so I know where to go
yeah which actually I mean in comparison
Whoopi Goldberg get her frustrated rant
pails recently on her tepid morning
coffee being compared to her
can Katrina oh she seems like she didn't
uh she knows she knows now she knows now
to walk a mile on your soggy shoes
whoopee
Rob Schneider this is big in the news
right now because he tweeted it out
surprised a lot of people Rob Schneider
came out and spoke out against Berkeley
and the suppression of free speech you
know he used to be a liberal Rob
Schneider yeah you know coming out more
and more you know it doesn't surprise me
hanging out with the Sandler guys they
should be kind of more libertarian
um and I'm glad to see some celebrity
speaking out with this it really is
funny it's obviously it's not funny but
the irony in Antigua being nothing but
fascists is not lost on people like Rob
Schneider apparently though some did
question his motivations because
Berkeley and I can kind of understand
they put an official moratorium on the
upcoming release deuce Bigalow three
fascist gigolo oh so it seems like they
had a little bit more of a reason how
big the burden of foot that's impressive
i I don't know we spared no expense so
here's something else it happened in
Berkeley Everett just went viral it was
lighting the Twitter ablaze so before we
get to sanctuary cities this is the last
topic we think we needed to hit on
because gosh it was flooding my Twitter
timeline and we wrote about it at lieth
creditor calm at berkeley
this person was crumpling up a Donald
Trump flag I guess you would say sir
like a promotional trainer yeah and
someone called them out for it and this
person who is transgender does what
transgenders at berkeley do watch the
clip
yeah there's a big the honest-to-god
truth it will have maybe love Blair
White be a tiebreaker later Bob I read
the story at campus reform first and it
just said this transgender individual
yeah which for those who are wonders
nothing what what do you think one may
say opposes motivation it creates more
questions because what do you think you
think this is a a male to female
transgender do you think it's a female
female is it confirmed to transgender
and transgender they just wrote
transgenders when the story first came
out transgender mistaken identity thing
though I can see why what do you sell
look do you think male the female
transgender do you think it's female to
me at that point it's I'm gonna go with
male to female you think it's male to
female who still dresses and looks like
a male on accident you're a different
theory all to God I think looking at
this individual it looks like I would
guess lesbian actually I think you just
think it's a big old tree a lesbian I
think we're so quick to pull the trainee
trigger we don't get serious or quick to
publish right before chance it's your we
don't consider it a good old-fashioned
Dyke honestly it is hard to identify
which is you know this is what Bill Nye
should be using which is why we go to
science it is important that you know
this is not a mainstream [ __ ] this is
actually the campuses trans to takus
which is as it's known scientifically
this is actually found exclusively on
campuses not to be confused with its
parent species just the average
mainstream [ __ ] because on campus when
you add gender fluidity of course the
idea of pansexual there are multiple
combinations it's true so in analyzing
the specimen using science we can
actually get to the bottom of this we
can make an inference let's do it so
okay
in the male-to-female column that this
might be a male to female transgender
right away height obviously clear-cut
very tall individual that adds a 20%
likelihood that this person is a male
cofactor with that is the circumference
the diameter is matter of fact it's an
exponential gain not necessarily linear
but we're just going for the sake of
argument here a 60% increased chance of
it being a male sure I don't have you
see this they're jailed - cleft chin
yeah yeah that makes a 14 percent more
likely chance of it being a male so so
that would seem if you look at the
percentages which I didn't before this
so please don't fact-check our math it
would seem pretty heavy this is like a
male yeah well okay because this person
says I'm a woman but why would a male to
female transgender look so much like a
man so there is an argument to be made
that if this this is a person who is a
female to male transgender but who is
fluid and identifies as a female so in
the female to male column there are some
things to look for when analyzing the
subspecies first off the complete and
total lack of muscle tone as you see
that would be a 40% chance yeah likely
to this reasonable female here the
obvious sub contain yzma Murray tissue
32 percent more likely to be a female if
you look at the vocal tones and the body
language it displays great emotional
instability 82 percent more likelihood
that it's a female right there and then
of course this individual claims to be a
female but on campus that only increases
the likelihood of them being an actual
female by 1% we should note that with
these studies there is a plus/minus
percentage point of inaccuracy yeah so
statistically it gets us into murky
territory it seems like so male the
female female to male any of you change
your opinions no I'm sticking with that
because it there's some detective work
something upon further inspection close
up not gauge erred when you look at the
shirt the shirt says left over crack
purgatory and right there upon further
examination a cat pun t-shirt it gives
it a hundred percent likely that this is
just your run-of-the-mill homosexual
we known as the faggus Flambeau a kiss
100% solve that mystery yes it was tough
thank you
science we understand there's you see
what you're doing to us I'm a woman guys
what and what's so funny is when the
left is such you're trying to say this
person was provoking the transgender if
you watch the video person goes oh what
a big man you are crumpling up a flag
the I'm a woman and the guy doesn't
respond with the smartass comment he
just goes I don't think he set out to
insult the transgender no I think he
just was upset at someone behaving like
a child crumpling up by the way is a
Nazi patch hotseat that's outside of
actual Nazi Germany I don't know I don't
know how this must have found the you
know time to do that outside of fighting
The Incredibles because with everyone's
special no one is all right nice Vox
sanctuary cities this is something a lot
of people wanted me to get into
sanctuary cities describe exactly what
it was and I was going to do it this
week but Vox beat me to it
this week and here's the thing if
someone disagrees with me we'll have
Blair White who disagrees me on some
issues if someone disagrees with some
points of view on this show that that's
fine my I don't have an issue with MSNBC
you don't really hear us taking a lot of
shots at MSNBC much more so CNN because
Chris Cuomo thinks of himself as my god
an actual journalist so when Vox goes
out and tries to act as though they're
simply describing what a sanctuary city
is and what's occurring in practice and
you draw your own conclusions when it's
clearly biased reporting that's where my
antennae go up so let's let Vox describe
for you what a sanctuary city is first
what our sanctuary cities there are
cities and counties in the u.s. that
limit their cooperation with immigration
enforcement which falls under federal
jurisdiction these policies are
different in different places in Chicago
it means city employees aren't supposed
to share residents immigration status
with other people in Washington DC it
means police officers are barred from
asking residents about their immigration
status that's actually that's fair
enough I would say that's pretty
accurate sure for people what you seem
visually wash
explaining the situation but they are
explaining it I a that's a pretty fair
initial explanation it basically comes
down to cities and cities that don't
have to enforce the federal immigration
law because federally coming here
illegally is a crime keyword there
illegally it's a crime and the
punishment for that crime is really just
being deported that's pretty pretty
lenient punishment if you think about it
punishment is you end up back in your
room it's a go to your room timeout
only forever and your room is a crap
hole if you come from Mexico so that's
what's happening it is local law
enforcement in certain cities not being
required or refusing to carry out
national immigration orders so Mathare
is I hate to use word nuance there
there's a little bit more to it to that
and we'll get into the rebuttal more
with Vox here but that is what it really
comes down to the feds versus local it's
like every old cop move ever seen why
can't you two just get along so okay the
next clip next up from box but often it
comes down to this how does a local
police officer handle an unauthorized
immigrant that he's already arrested for
some other reason was that a question
deport him deport the person who's here
illegally okay it's multiple choice
which one was it h2 pencil the scantron
lead other options please retire from
law enforcement please refer to any ID
give me your badge and your gun okay if
that's not enough if that doesn't seem
like the argument is substantiated
enough that hey you should enforce the
law and deport an illegal immigrant let
me throw some numbers at you an illegal
immigrant we've talked about this on the
show before cost the taxpayers
five thousand dollars annually the cost
of incarcerated a felon or one of these
illegal immigrants can be thirty two
thousand if they're being arrested for
committing a serious crime comparably
flying them home courtesy of ice air is
between seven hundred and two thousand
dollars also they're a criminal so
you've captured someone here illegally
why through an auxilary crime which they
were committing you've captured them
committing another crime that's how you
fold them over or you've arrested them
and then you happen to find out that
they're also here illegally to
double-secret crimes Merry Christmas
officer Trump it's been gift-wrapped for
you
that's clip where it gets out around the
unit community any time you interact
with local police it could mean
deportation eventually immigrants will
be afraid to call the police even when
they're the victims of crime or the
witnesses to it and then immigrants
become easy targets what the forty
illegal another other so if you deport
illegal immigrants other criminals will
be afraid to interact with the police
yes this is the crux of their argument -
let me preface this they get into very
quickly the constitutionality now
constitutionally local law enforcement
are not required to enforce federal law
and for basically law enforcement it
would fall under federal jurisdiction
okay however they're not really being
asked to enforce federal something would
fall under federal jurisdiction what
they're being asked to do is provide a
48-hour wit 48-hour waiting period for
ice to come in basically okay hold on
I'll get my keys I'm coming to pick them
up they're just asking local law
enforcement to keep them there long
enough so that ice can come in and do
their job and deport these people
illegally but let's go with the crux of
their argument here which again goes
back to the science of feelings right as
bill and I talked about it um the
premise do you really think that illegal
immigrants right now are calling their
local man in blue backing the blue
fervently for peace disturbances or
domestic disputes
Los Angeles Police Department
okay can I have their address and your
name sir what they are crafty
they need to bring in the feds okay
since Vox is and hopefully you've
realized what's happened they described
sanctuary cities accurately yeah we are
far off on speculation here at that's
the point yes and we fully admit what we
provide opinion on this show and fact
check us that's fine sometimes we're
wrong okay but Vox is trying to present
this as a nonpartisan view of sanctuary
cities so since Vox is speculating here
that in what is supposed to be a
non-biased video let's think this
through what does it play it through as
Gavin says do you really think the net
result of enforcing deportation laws
will be that taxpaying police compliant
citizens in a Latino paradise will now
become an enclave to crime I don't think
the evidence will bear that as a matter
of fact I think the evidence will show a
very contrary inclusion in late January
2017 shortly after he got into office
President Donald Trump signed an
executive order that opens the door to
withholding federal funds from sanctuary
cities or counties the wording of that
order is vague and it's already being
challenged in federal court but if
Trump's plan does move forward he could
put local law enforcement officers
across the country in a lose-lose
situation for them deciding whether to
honor a detainer request is often about
choosing between financial security on
one hand and public safety on the other
what first off what and yes yes exactly
okay if a policeman sometimes called a
law man's address refuses to enforce
that I've seen the Steven Seagal show if
they refuse to enforce the law that
ensures a safety in order of its
citizenry the higher-ups
or even the taxpayers who fund those who
are supposed to carry out the law
sometimes cut the purse strings for the
law man was anyone else not aware of
this sort of unwritten will actually
written but you know
I can't can't get it if you don't
enforce the law we remove law from your
title and you're just a man or a woman
anymore like I sure I'm going to give
you $20 for a pepperoni pizza
okay let's mute abala cuz that's what
they say and then they take your money
but they don't give you a pizza yeah and
the owner of the place says well you
know we're gonna fire you why cuz he
didn't make pizzas is that hate speech
you racist
well the meatball was but the analogy
remains that's clip if the federal
government issues a detainer request and
the local police department refuses to
accept it the state government can step
in by taking away one of the state
funding streams from the local police
that's what happened in Texas in 2017
the governor of the great state of Texas
Greg Abbott has declared he will sign a
law banning sanctuary cities he's
already issued an order that cuts
funding to those sanctuary cities this
is dangerous and I will not allow it as
governor of Texas okay here I baby Fox's
argument as we see rests entirely on
feelings again they're claiming public
safety here right this is the argument
they're saying yeah cops have to choose
between deporting illegal immigrants or
public safety cooperation yeah or public
safety well on a second what does that
mean does that mean this are we talking
safety of legal immigrants who obey the
laws on a day to day basis are we
compromising their safety by deporting
illegal immigrants enforcing deportation
makes them less safe I'd like to see a
reference on this from Vox any reference
or are we talking about public safety
specifically of communities consisting
of illegal aliens because they might
live in fear of actual laws being
enforced it's like they're arguing for
drug dealers hey somebody stole my drugs
can you uh what you know it's me you're
gonna get trumped they're gonna say that
you just calling it just comparing its
criminals gee so instead of that
hypothetical that Vox presupposes let's
look at the evidence here um guess what
illegal immigrants here tend to commit
significant amounts of crime not all
immigrants not all immigrants are
committing crime but crime is high in
the illegal immigrant community it turns
out when you skirt the law and
flagrantly disregard the law
you get here and you're not even on the
books for the law to find you you may
not have a ton of respect for the law
and this is what brought this is the
single issue that brought Donald Trump
to power because people were people who
are here legally and I come from a
family of it not a family my mom is
french-canadian should even speak the
language she learned the language she's
a taxpaying citizen I am the biggest
advocate of doing it right by the books
that are confined but people are tired
of the illegal immigration and this is
what this this is what brought Donald
Trump to power everyone thought that he
was racist and they said Donald Trump's
racist for wanting to enforce the laws
let's paint him let's tar and feather
him and the American people will try and
distance themselves from the racism of
believing and enforcing immigration laws
no he won and now arrests of
undocumented immigrants have gone up 32%
and guess what that guess what the
result of that is I'm gonna guess in the
Elimination might beat down that speech
down sixty-one percent down sixty-one
percent since election they even
PolitiFact said that's mostly true and
mostly because apparently we need more
data to be drawn on this and also
because it's PolitiFact and they suck so
even they say mostly true sixty-one
percent since election day so what is it
what is the net result here if we think
about it is a net result to get a few
certain forcing immigration laws all
that's going to happen is we're going to
see communities decimated and people are
going to be less safe or if you enforce
immigration laws on illegal immigrants
instead of sauntering on over and having
every huh Tom Dick and Harry and member
of the Latin Kings following suit
they're gonna say no guy you me what'd
he say anybody say ID please let me back
on I say mean what he's me
[Laughter]
so Big Chief and Percy we're gonna get I
didn't say they were drug deals I just
did a racist accent so maybe when you
look at the result we deport illegal
immigrants illegal immigration Goes Down
and crime seems to go down in cities
with illegal immigration along with it
maybe maybe just maybe the public safety
that we're talking about it's a public
safety meaning those who are legally
documented law-abiding citizens will
actually be better off maybe all of this
evidence points toward the fact that the
goals are not incongruent that police
don't have to decide between enforcing
immigration laws and keeping the public
safe but that actually enforcing
immigration laws does keep the public
safe
Oh Vox you almost had us to Dean Cain
coming up next
[Music]
home body break with steven crowder and
not gay jerry summer is a great time to
be active outside and enjoy your
favorite activities like tending to this
garden but it's not without its tests as
you can see with these beads I'm highly
allergic the good news is that you can
create a homemade solution without the
use of any synthetic unnatural or harsh
chemicals that could harm the
environment just mix three parts vinegar
and a couple drops of peppermint and a
household spray ball mix and allow to
sit for 20 minutes then gently spray on
the affected area and watch as your
unwanted guests return to greener
pastures the key is to find the
effective rate with steven crowder and
not gauge aaron sponsored by mud club
[Music]
figured our next guess would appreciate
the cot top because that's actually it's
it's a big part of the ancient Japanese
way and I think is like 1/16 Japanese
what is but you know him you love me is
one of the regulars here in ladder with
Crowder at real Dean Cain and you and
Dean are good we're good now Dean take
it down the show brother we're good
we're good now I thought we talked about
this yeah let's talk about afterwards
well you should don't talk about it on
the air yeah let's just avoid talking
about it with me you go ahead and be
that way Jared we'll just we'll just
push it aside now so you've been hosting
the Today Show a lot and you were
talking about your recent project there
tell us about this this documentary
because I wanted to talk about something
else from your Twitter because as you
know that's always news now but talk
about this documentary first are those
two documents one's a feature that's
called architects of denial comes out
October 6th okay
and the other is is it television
special comes back comes out later in
the fall and they're both dealing with
genocide in a way specifically
architects of denial is dealing with
genocide genocides that occur all over
the world and have occurred specifically
targeting the Armenian Genocide yeah
that started in 1915 until 1923 where
where 1.5 million Armenians were killed
900,000 Greeks and 750 thousand
Assyrians it's a whole bunch of people
awful stuff we hadn't even coined the
term genocide at that point in time but
it didn't catch on it became more of a
fad later on yeah well you know you the
honest truth is Hitler has that quote
and he says you know after all who
remembers the Armenians and that's what
it's about
because if you don't call it what it is
and you don't name them they name it and
label it you can just pretend you know
it never existed it's that history
written by the victors kind of thing so
this documentary goes explores that goes
through it all provides it more
incontrovertible proof and and it's it's
it's hopefully something that can shine
a light on the situation
so people like there are people who deny
it you know anybody yeah well you know
it's funny that you lay that up for me
Cinque from The Young Turks too he wrote
a whole TV yes he wrote a whole I don't
I don't know who lays up like this is
that it what kind of federal it's oh you
gotta be high up
yeah apparently Dean Cain moonlights the
harlem globetrotter does i knew about
this yeah there are some people out
there who deny it and I'll be honest I
don't know a ton about it outside of
what I've read because I knew that this
guy denied it I sort of a you know
briefly touched on it in history class
and I thought well you know Hahn a
second maybe I'm wrong and I smug there
I thought maybe I'm wrong
and then when I look into it did seem in
like incontrovertible proof why is it an
issue that some people deny ever
occurred you'd have to ask [ __ ] that
question I'd love to see him on everyone
see that I would watch that for sure yes
I think you know and even call
themselves the Young Turks I mean those
are the groups that purpose rate of the
genocide it's writing believable yeah
people deny it because it's ugly you
know there's a lot of things you don't
want to face you look at the stuff that
we did you know in the United States to
the Native American population there's
some ugly stuff but if you own it you
can move on you can call it what it is
and you move on obviously I didn't do it
you didn't do it but our ancestors did
and sure and that's what took that's
what took place and calling what it is
is very important you know but one of
the night they want to make it go away
pretend it never existed it's like you
know the Iranians denying the Holocaust
good luck with that but no I'm bonitas
Yad I remember seeing him God there was
no Holocaust the that kind of stuff is
insane also none of our men here like
big it does not happen in Iran they're
all about the punani you stop it goes
back to Baghdad Bob committing suicide
by the hundreds of the gates Baghdad no
no no they're not as a matter fact if
you look at you if you look just like
the if you look at the heat-seeking
cameras from the American war jets going
overhead you can just see guys in the
hills they get lonely
Dean let me ask you this so you tweeted
this out and I don't want to be one of
the guys who just ooh catchy headline
someone said you should run for office
and you did say you were seriously
considering that now because we've asked
you that before and you're like yeah
probably not
are you seriously considering that or
was that tongue-in-cheek and do you need
to running me here's the thing there's
times where
my business is ugly it's ugly but
politics is not when you're in it
yeah it's I'm looking at our new senator
our newly elected senator from the
United States from California
our US Senator Kamala Harris and the
things she was tweeting I've never
looked at her Twitter feed I started
looking her Twitter feed and I started
losing my mind yeah you know one of them
in particular was an undocumented
immigrant is not a criminal I mean so I
tweeted back in what country in what
country you know cuz pick another
country you try to go to Canada or
Mexico or somewhere in Europe guess what
yeah well Mexico's pretty pretty rough
on that too you don't necessarily get
out unscathed did she respond to you no
of course not well I don't know I mean
you're still being cain't I thought she
respond so fun stuff I just see a lot of
rhetoric coming out that is right on the
party line that's extremely left I'm
socially very liberal so in California
if I decided to run for US Senate if
Feinstein does go ahead and retire if
that's the case you know being socially
liberal but fiscally in foreign
policy-wise being very conservative I
think that matches a countrywide very
well and certainly within California so
we'll see the only thing is you sure
it's a good idea to keep appearing on
this program if that's the case I am Not
Afraid at all I break right I just won't
I don't I'm not gonna fall you know the
only one who has to continue do that is
a Senator Ted Cruz and Governor Mike
Huckabee Carly Fiorina fell off mr.
politicians and then afterward oh my
gosh no and they play they play spot the
[ __ ] and they did some jokes so I
think it's changed note now for better
or worse I think Trump has opened that
up or people think yeah okay so he was
on a show or someone said something
offensive or one time he tweeted
something that someone didn't like I
don't think that's enough of a
deal-breaker
with the voters anymore aside from the
ones who will hate you anyway well I
agree with that I think that's a good
thing
it's better that way because at the end
of the day I don't care what image
you're gonna project out there you're
still a human being and you still do all
the regular things and make silly jokes
jokes have become this thing that is
such a big deal admit jokes have to be
made there must be
jokes if there's not jokes you can't
joke about something if it's so serious
you can't joke about it then it's either
you know horrific like gassing children
in Syria or you have no sense of humor
yeah not saying that gassing children
and serious funny no no he's not saying
that and people not write jokes about
that into tomorrow show map not just
because Dean Cain is just yeah you know
it's one of those things whenever
someone comes out and they say and
publicly can you believe that so-and-so
said this and even if it's a for example
what was it that commentator we're
talking about and the Young Turks we're
talking about it he said Serena Williams
and her boyfriend husband ran baby he
said oh it's that baby it's going to be
like like chocolate milk that was it
they're like can you believe he said
that like the color like a light bright
like a light brown yeah
chocolate milk I mean it was well since
it couldn't possibly be less
controversial and then it makes you you
know do some research we're talking
about it yesterday because I say this
person is actually nicknamed nasty and
well ha a second you just said that him
saying chocolate milk is nasty so why is
he nicknamed nasty is it because he says
non nasty things like this and I think
it actually forces more people to look
into your history to look into context
and they realize it's not at all that
offensive because the left has pushed
everything as offensive and that's the I
don't think almost anything is offensive
right no I'm not getting a fin bicep and
I think that's the way it should be you
know on my Twitter feed I do have a
quote from Martin Luther King talking
about his I have a dream speech and
talking about how he has a dream that
one day you know his children will be
judged not by the color of his skin but
by the content of their character I
don't see race I don't see sex I don't
remember I see sex oh yeah I don't see
that don't care none of that means
anything to me so I don't there's no
special dispensation to anybody if you
don't drink that's fine you don't you're
dead you're dead if you don't see sex
with Dean Cain sorry Dean I'm sorry it's
just thank you you're you know I'm gonna
make it what is it a Jeff gift gift you
know it doesn't matter what how you
pronounce it someone right now on
Twitter will say that you're wrong
so I've done both and either way and you
know I say to that person they're wrong
yeah I know and now you're gonna
never-ending never-ending tweets never
name queen
it's like the caliber war were you like
hey nine million nine millimeter of 45
only and then someone comes in three
it's just never ends careers over and
then you're I don't - stopping power 45
just gonna throw it out there yeah okay
no I don't mind any of it I just I'd
rather someone carry a 38 or a 380 then
nothing really rule your boys will just
cure pointy-stick sure about that three
all the way yes exactly a puncture some
holes so uh so if you so it could be a
possibility if you maybe think about
running for office I would I mean I
would encourage you to because obviously
you remove a lot of the arguments at the
left that you know you're you're a Nazi
you're hateful because you've got you've
got some ethnicity and you I don't know
what it is but it's enough to check your
box it's Japanese don't qualify is white
I guess if right this way I have more
Japanese in me than Elizabeth Warren has
Native American this is true do i oh
there's a joke it's a joke right it's a
joke about the land of lay a Land
O'Lakes butter lady and then it let us
know if you do and we will want to talk
about it and have you on and discuss
this documentary we have to get going we
have Blair white coming up at real Dean
Cain man I'm looking forward to it we'll
see maybe he'll be one of our elected
representatives stay tuned
Blair white
[Music]
just one percent well Jiro Jared said
two percent I think we should be safe go
for two if just a couple percent of you
people out there loud with credit calm
slash mug club join up listen it allows
us to hire a lot of the other people
here on YouTube allows us to create a
coalition of a lot of other people
around who've been screwed by the new
anti I guess would say aunty
controversial speech algorithms um
it's nine dollars annual at sixty nine
for students veterans or active military
and now we actually the ability on the
CR T V app for you to listen audio when
you're on the go can't tell you how much
we appreciate it we've seen a ton of
people signing up for for mullet not
only to get this hand etched mug but you
do get louder with crowd or daily you
get knocked a Jared in Courtney's
morning grinders you also get access to
mark levin michelle malkin plenty of
other people in you can help keep the
doors open and everyone employed here's
one thing i will say there's a 7-day
free trial there but i also know that a
lot of you cannot be bothered to click
off of this URL I don't blame you I'm a
child of the millennial era
Maleny was of the millennium I'm a part
of the millennial generation I don't
know the Joey's we're mostly more likely
to use paper towels napkins as
Millennials I find that to be true also
we were all I thought they were the same
thing but true guess how many napkins
you can stuff in a mug well you know the
purchase want to find out I I didn't
know what I was talking about was I
talking about before this millennial is
talking about so there will be actually
here on YouTube because YouTube is going
hard and fast now with their Google
algorithms for move fig news we're going
to be offering two weeks free of The
Daily Show on YouTube two weeks free
right now there's still a seven day free
trial but we are going to give away the
show for two weeks for a limited period
of time
tune in to see when that will be in our
videos or maybe next week's show it's
likely going to be within the next month
two weeks completely free after that you
can decide if it's if it's enough value
to you or not one thing you should know
when you purchase Cape for example ESPN
is a good example ESPN gets $6 per cable
subscription and they're still laying
people off just to let a lot of people
off places like CNN a lot of these news
companies they don't make their money
off of that but not a majority of their
money off of advertising they make it
off of cable subscriptions so when you
purchase cable you're not just kind of
you're directly putting money in the
pockets of people
who seek to destroy everything you hold
dear in a very tangible way when you
purchase cable so if you're gonna unplug
in a very tangible way you can assist
with people who not only are creating
this show and the shows that see our TV
but grow it really quickly we don't want
to see people out there with patreon
struggling to get by behind the scene
they know a lot of people are scared and
I think you're gonna see us helping a
lot of them really soon ladder with
credit or comm slash mug club sign up
today 16 if you're just even if you're a
yellow belt in karate don't tell anybody
you do karate because that could invite
a fight but you can even get the student
discount just type in student type in a
lot of us better not cop slash more
clever cool like that
[Music]
that's because apparently this is a
common thing for robots to do in 2017
you think we did better robot I've never
understood that apparently it's a part
of the robot dance I've never seen
someone do the robot without doing that
portion of it glad to have our next
guest on hot Sun coming you yeah at
Blair at Miss MS Blair white on Twitter
the channel is Blair White X I believe
on YouTube Blair thank you for being on
the program yeah thanks for having me
this is highly requested I think on both
ends it is I know and you you you didn't
did not like me at one point and I was I
was saddened because I've actually
always liked some of your content even
if we don't always agree and I'm glad
that we're finally able to get you on
the show yeah I think that was like a
year no that we had our little Twitter
suspect and you could still dislike me
most people do I wouldn't blame you at
all no sometimes you kind of annoy me
but I still like your content overall I
mean I think that in common I hate
myself believe me this is the right
place for self-loathing so Blair for our
audience people who might necessarily be
familiar with you or people listening
sort of terrestrially explain them I
mean you're you're transgender would you
consider yourself I don't want to
mislabel you conservative libertarian
all right just sort of a Trump fan how
would you consider yourself I am a Nazi
and YouTube just be monetized I have
always roughly described my political
leanings as center-right and actually
just took the political compass test and
it came out as pretty much exactly
center-right so I guess that's fair to
say okay what is that like we've had I
think I think you're friends with Theron
Mayer we've had Thayer and Mayer on the
show it must be pretty tough because
obviously you know transgenders get
ostracized and we're not--we're no
strangers to great [ __ ] jokes in the
show but we're not strangers to any
jokes in the show we're not gonna lie
about it but then so you get that side
of it but then you get the hate this
fight from the left being an expected
sort of contributing member of the far
left LGBTQ AI actually I a I just read
this yesterday in Austin IA is how you
change to the gay I changed it again it
is a toast q hi a and then
another a it's two A's for a lie yeah
yeah I don't know how much you know
about like the general reaction to my
channel from that side of the political
spectrum but I'm basically seen as the
Antichrist of the transgender community
it's really ridiculous okay I just go
against it's quite a lot of what
especially you know transgender
activists right preach because I think
that a lot of the times the people that
they prop up to advocate on their behalf
and speak about their issues are insane
okay I was going to say that you really
do you you it must be tough you get the
short end of the stick because I tell
you what we get even on a personal level
I will say this behind the scenes nearly
every transgender person outside of
Theron Meyer we've had in the program
has been a crazy person and we've either
had to block them afterward like they we
had people send us books you know who we
just respectfully disagreed with people
I won't name names that people can go
watch that you longest emails you have a
verse like gosh you know so when these
people go out and they're your
ambassadors you must be sitting there
with it just it must be like a permanent
bruise on your forehead yes because I
don't like the fact that transgender is
politicized at all because to me it
needs to remain a medical issue a
psychological issue you know the issue
of neurology and [ __ ] like it shouldn't
be I don't know if I can curse I'm sorry
you can't
Jared's job is just harder okay it
shouldn't be politicized at all so if it
is gonna be politicized I at least want
like smart people advocating for it and
there just isn't
you know instead you get you know the
Stephanie whatever his name is that 35
year old Jeff Malone yes eyeko it's
Stefan nice very clever naming there
yeah yeah you get like Caitlyn Jenner
who every once in a blue moon said
something smart but is overall just a
really creepy individual you get no just
the worst people and I'm so I'm sitting
here I mean I'm not gonna lie like in my
life being trans is not that huge of an
issue I don't walk around and feel the
weight of these activists because I have
a normal life but having those
conversations online it is frustrating
to get completed with those people so
option well let me ask you this because
I also know like conservatives though
they'll host
and then I'll just do an about-face so I
try to be transparent about where I line
up who concerns you more these activists
who represent you or maybe people like
me who are more conservative going you
know what I understand the bathroom
issue for parents and kids and it's a
conversation that needs to be had what
is it for you that's more troubling
which side I find that the people on the
right I relate to a lot more because to
me they're just easier to turn around on
certain things once they realize you're
not insane whereas the people on the
left they tend to just be very religious
about the beliefs on this topic so for
me I I definitely do get more [ __ ] from
the left
um but as far as the bathroom like the
bathroom issue neither side has really
done a good job of convincing me that
this issue matters as much as people
want it to be truthful Chanin is you
have on the right you have the people
who you know there's often this talking
point of if trans people use the
bathrooms they want there's going to be
a surge of rapes and assaults and all
the worst things in the world and on the
left you have people saying that if
trans people can't use the bathrooms
that they want or that they identify
with that they're gonna be assaulted and
murdered in the bathroom and they're
gonna kill themselves over the stress of
it and I'm just like oh my God all these
histrionics over bathrooms it's like I
don't like being expected to suspend my
knowledge of how the real world works
tomorrow we have arguments because the
world like people are not none of this
is happening in bathrooms none of it
well I'm not suspending belief in the
real world so not a big Bill Nye fan
I'll take it he did this whole spectrum
well here's the issue I think a lot of
you understand so you get Charlotte
right and there was a city ordinance
basically said you have to let anyone
use any bathroom they want and then the
state said no you know that's not we're
gonna do it because businesses are going
to be harmed with this no we're gonna
make it you use your biological gender
and then so I would imagine we'd
probably agree that if a private
business wants to make a decision you
know for example in New York landlords
can be sued for using improper pronouns
I mean it is a rulebook that changes I
would imagine even for you it's hard to
follow sometimes we don't know what
we're supposed to do or say and then of
course people like me don't do it anyway
that's
sometimes empathy because trans people
have been around for a long time but the
issue and the politicization of trans
people is what three or four years old I
mean this issue came up in 2013 or
something yeah so to me I have no
expectation for anyone who you know this
isn't a part of the world so like fully
understand it especially when like you
said the rule book does change so often
there are people in the trans community
and that take issue with the fact that I
say the word transsexual because they
think that it should be transgender
because it should be you know more
all-encompassing there people say that I
can't say the word [ __ ] because that's
a slur and it's equated was the n-word
it's like I know you didn't just say the
T word yes you say the T word exactly
that shows you how different it is well
you know what that's because I got a lot
of flack at one point is anything that
you bring up transsexual and this was
because I had a psychiatrist on my show
who works with a lot of trends
transsexual people and as well as
transvestites and she made the
differentiation and she said
transvestites are people who dress up in
women's clothing sometimes they put on
makeup sometimes it makes a little but
they don't go through the sexual
reassignment surgery transsexuals are
people who go through the sexual
reassignment surgery said clinically
that's how we define them and I said
okay do most transgenders go through the
sexual recession no less than twelve
percent which is the high figure she
said no more of today's transgenders
would have much more in common with
yesterday's transvestites than actual
what was determined transsexuals and
people got really mad when I tweeted
that out I'm not saying I'm right but it
does seem within the bounds of reason
you can you can tell me what why I'm
wrong I'm open to it no that was
actually I think the spot that we had a
year ago when you said that okay and
honestly since then I have really come
to see your point because when I
initially got angry at you for saying
not it was I think I was like a month or
two into doing YouTube videos and I had
not really toe into the trans community
and how they really feel I always
assumed all trans people were just like
me and so coming from that assumption
you see someone saying that trans people
aren't different from like cross
dressers and transvestites and I'm like
oh yes I am but then you look at the
fact that the definition of chance has
been expanded so greatly yeah
people do fall into that umbrella now
witches which is crazy and that's one of
the your rarity I will say this you're a
rarity because we had a mayor on here
just just Herbst who said you know we'll
the promise we'd like need barely
passable
well this mayor tossed on a muumuu and
called obviously there's some buy-in
here Blair III salute that and that's
that's that I think what's inflated the
number I'm sure you've seen like the
number of transgenders in the United
States has gone up so rapidly well most
of them are not super committed and a
lot of them just go back yeah and what
concerns me even more than that because
listen people can clothe themselves or
they belong you can label yourself as
non-binary transgender transsexual trans
and eater I don't care but the thing is
what concerns me is the amount of new
cases of trans children I think in
London there's like a four times
increase in the amount of kids being
referred to gender clinics in hopes of
you know going on puberty blocker isn't
hormone then it just really I don't know
if you know my stance on kids
transitioning but I am vehemently
against it so that concerns me even more
I I think it's well here there's a
difference right but I also think
children should not be in in charge of
making any serious decisions regarding
you know their life's path certainly not
sexuality at that point in their life or
gender because right when I was a kid I
said when I grow up I want to be a woman
so that I can still have sleepovers my
brother and I shared bunk beds and I was
like oh that's gonna be a bummer I want
to be a woman when I grow up so I can
share bunk beds with my brother and be
his wife my parents like you don't know
how that works but now you watch the
Jenner special and this person goes well
my daughter said I'm a boy how that's
that how much more clear can you get I'm
like be a parent she's four yeah it's
ridiculous and you know the idea that
because this is the top this is the part
that people don't like talking about
right and I don't even see enough you
know conservative talking points about
this which should be I think the main
focus if you're trying to argue against
children transitioning okay the fact
that transitioning sterilizes you going
on Peter Walker is making so you can
never have children that's a huge deal I
mean the conversations should just end
it I don't think beyond that there
should be any more conversation but
there
it's very frustrating that's why I
always bring up first it's like you
really think a 13 year old she has the
capacity to decide that they don't want
to ever have kids I transitioned at 20
okay and I have you been thinking about
because even at 20 most people don't
think about having kids and I'm sterile
and I can never have kids let's just
really shitty because you know I assume
as I get older I might want some right
so it's frustrating so you have some
issues even with the transition because
there are ramifications that now might
might change your outlook you think well
they're ramifications I will say this
from the time I was this back I was
struggling with gender dysphoria and it
only got worse as I got closer to
adulthood and so I came to a crossroads
where I said I can live with this
debilitating thing that's affecting my
life the moment I wake up someone I go
to sleep or I can transition and I would
never take it back because my quality of
life has increased more than I could
ever say but I would never endorse
transition per se and the reason I say
that is because I think there's a
specific small group of people in which
transitioning will actually alleviate
your describe mmm-hmm but I mean no
offense crowder but if you suddenly
picked up and transitioned I don't think
you'd be able to alleviate any just for
it don't think you'd be able to no
sports Xchange is not going to alleviate
this this mess here either way yeah
exactly so the fact that transition is
is posed as like the cure is I think
troubling because it's just not
effective for most people and you see
that with you know the suicide rates
right transition which are very similar
so for me it's hard to say don't do it
because it is kind of your best bet
there is no cure but part of the problem
with accepting transition as the end-all
be-all is it becomes politically
incorrect so you speak against it and
where does know something or research
into finding an actual cure it's like
what's interesting okay a couple things
that use injuring that you say cure
because people are now going to lump you
in with mike pence you know they're like
oh you're saying cure attention you know
but you're right I did notice you know
when I've watched your content and I've
read your tweets where you readily admit
that the suicide rate actually doesn't
get doesn't get much better in some
studies it actually gets
the more comprehensive studies that come
through and it really is fascinating to
see you're straightforward about that so
you secure well what do you mean as far
as research like a cure for gender
dysphoria how would you categorize
gender dysphoria and how do you want to
see it cured to use your work well it's
not how I would classify it mean genders
for it is classified by the DSM as a
mental disorder and so you know I'm not
an expert so I can't sit here and say
this will be the curve we should look
into this but I would like there to be
something you can take I'm not
advocating conversion therapy which is
more often than not throughout history
proven to be more barbaric and less
helpful and helpful right but but the
fact that as of now in 2017 the only
answer people have is transitioning when
it's so faulty I just wish there was
something else because it's very hard to
explain to someone who this is not a
part of their world how debilitating
genders for is and I know that on the
outside it just sounds like someone's
unhappy with our gender get over it but
it is actually very yeah it'll it'll f
you up so for me I would love for an end
to people suffering you know and people
twist that and I had to debate recently
with a non-binary gender queer feminist
you'd almost sounds like a joke but I
know that's how they said that I was
advocating for trans genocide because I
wanted there to be a care it's like oh
you wanted to be no more trans people
I'm like how do you twist that actually
I don't want anyone else to suffer with
this issue because well I I'm interested
it's ensuring that you say that because
first off depending on the medical
governing body they some of them have
said although it's not a mental disorder
now and we had a psychiatrist who said a
lot of this is political she said that
she treats it that way we've had several
who have discussed me have to discuss
off-air because they're afraid of
getting their license revoked if they
say this this is a psychiatric condition
listen I've suffered I've talked about
this from from mental health issues as
far as ADHD which manifested itself as
depression and it's one of those things
I try and talk about in the show
so if hopefully anyone else is out there
they can seek help a lot of the time
that is therapy sometimes a medicinal
sometimes psychiatric is Ness
Cerie so I'm not a stranger to that and
I'm aware of how that can make people
unhappy my issue is when we say okay
listen a suicide rate doesn't get any
better we don't think that putting
people in a shallow grave with a 41%
suicide rate is helping them it doesn't
mean we hate someone by saying you know
what this isn't healthy maybe let's find
another way to go about this now of
course we tell all the jokes and stuff
because a manly [ __ ] is hilarious
that'll never change you know that's
still funny was doing it well stephanie
is comedic gold you know it is
disturbing oh yes that's that's pretty
rough so it it it I mean do you
understand that from that point of view
people who maybe disagree and say like
listen I don't know that transgenderism
is a thing other than a mental disorder
and we want to help you and sometimes
that's a different route than the
transgender community wants yeah I will
say sometimes you know the fact that
it's a mental disorder can be weaponized
I think that's shitty I think that
sometimes the conversation just ends
with someone saying oh you're saying
it's like okay but what do you say has
anyone else if any other kind of
disorder I don't think so but I
completely understand that the left
tends to make moral arguments rather
than logical ones in the sense that
someone saying hey doesn't look like
it's helping that many people by
transitioning maybe we could seek other
you know options yes suddenly becomes oh
you want them to kill themselves it's
like they always dangle they're so
histrionic about it like if you don't
support them they're gonna kill
themselves it's like that's not on me
first of all right
second of all me advocating for you know
a cure or people to look into a carrot
isn't trans genocide so I relate to that
because I get the same thing yeah yeah
well it's it's interesting that we're
talking about this I'm glad I think we
agree on more than we disagree I think
the one I think the one issue on which
we disagree is and here's the thing we
disagree but my point is this unlike
people like Bill Nye I'm willing to
engage in a conversation you know if I
cite a study that the you know the brain
can occur after cross hormone sexual
replacement therapy I know there are
studies that would contradict that and
then I know there are subsequent studies
that contradict to that
don't have the time with every single
article or video to say well then they
just say there's a study and go down the
tree branch but I'm willing to entertain
the idea of a conversation even if we
disagree the issue and I think what's
going to be bad for the trans community
is people like Bill Nye first off who
don't know anything about it just saying
gender is a spectrum and they do a slam
poetry session about it and my god
that's not a good ad campaign for you
know and you know some people view me as
like an advocate of sorts just on the
other side it was never really my
intention in fact when I first started
my channel I spoke mostly about men's
rights and I would speak about anti
Wyatt sentiments in the media and stuff
like that and I think it's just kind of
a byproduct so that a lot of people come
to my channel and they're only
perception of trans people before me was
the rally Dennises and the Milo
Stewart's of the world and what Bill Nye
says and so it's like refreshing to them
so I guess it's like my products but I'm
I know me as an advocate and by no means
a spokesperson for the trans community I
just kind of speak from my experience
and what I research yeah that's also
very moving I think to a lot of people
you know we have chatted with with aids
in the show who talked about the gay
community's gay he talks about the gay
community and he talks about the HIV
epidemic community yeah he was he was
sexually molested and HIV and so he
advocates for disclosure laws and then
we had what's his name Zack Ford from
Think Progress who advocates against
disclosure laws I feel like when you
hear people I think I don't shouldn't
say feel like I think people like you
and myself can find a lot more common
ground against someone who's saying you
know what I think it should be a crime
to ask people to disclose their aids
with sexual partners I think this is so
radical but they again the radical left
has the media pulpit so that's
mainstream transgenderism now yeah and I
think with most things the truth is
always somewhere in the middle and
especially especially with this issue
people tend to talk past each other
and it's frustrating because like I said
I don't like the position of it I would
prefer if the state in the medical field
entirely because in my opinion that's
the only place but can we discuss
properly and they're even issues over
there when they discuss it because
there's conflicting studies like you
said sure
it's just about I mean we talked about
the suicide rates of trans people there
are also a lot of studies that show that
the suicide rate becomes less common
with familial acceptance and having a
supportive family which i think is great
and so i think that's an important
message to put out there but what I
think is also important to say is that
there should be no authoritarianism
surrounding this topic there shouldn't
be laws that dictate how you should
interact with people or you know I think
that's crazy and I think it's a bad look
why would someone ever want to hire a
trans person who instantly becomes a
liability to their business and they'll
slip on a pronoun like that's why I is
why I say even though on the surface it
may seem like I would have more of an
issue with you actually is them because
they're the one that put me in this
position in the first place right so and
most a lot of them aren't willing to
entertain a discussion even if you said
you know what I'm gonna come double
barrels blaze and I have a problem with
what you said we'd still welcome you on
the show I mean I think I'd like the
thing we have a pretty decent track
record of doing that it's just pretty
hard to get people who who disagree with
us on the program so it's rare that we
get productive discussions but hey let
me ask you this maybe you can be a
tiebreaker here did you see the Berkeley
well I don't know it was reported as a
transgender do you see the Berkeley
transgender who ripping up the Trump
thing and threatening to beat the crap
out of the guys the big redhead okay is
that a male to female transgender that a
female to male is it just a genderqueer
person because we couldn't figure it out
because any article just a transgender
um I probably have about as good of a
day an idea as you do okay okay but from
what I read I think it was a male to
female transsexual because they got well
transsexual trans person because they
got upset over being called male so you
can get the representation thing there
was a zoe tur I think was yeah she's
almost strangled ben shapiro yeah like
what better argument for the fact that
like trans women are like inherently
feminine and like free bill brain to
have these burly like dudes walking
around threatening to kick people with a
flea well here's the thing i don't know
because if it is a male to female we
actually were doing a whole we were
doing a whole analysis earlier if it is
a male to female transgender it's a male
to female transgender who then
dresses and cuts his or her hair like a
male like I don't know the rulebook at
this point and what's funny is I saw the
left is kind of reporting on it you know
this guy committed hate speech I don't
think the guy knew that was a
transgender he said Oh big man you know
like crumpling up the flag and then goes
I'm a woman and the guy doesn't say
anything that's it this is what I said
before it's about suspending being
forced to suspend your knowledge of how
the world world actually works when it
comes to pronouns people act like it's a
thought process it's not using someone's
pronouns is a subconscious you know
judgment based on secondary sex
characteristics in other words what
you've used someone has someone walks
into a store they look like a woman
you're gonna say ma'am it's not a
thought and so this idea that you should
walk around and like ask people their
pronouns before you talk it's just not
real right it doesn't work like that
you know yeah well and that's why I
didn't use pronouns when I brought in
the show because I'm liable to slip up
with you I would drive very likely just
instinctly say she with Mayor Jess
Herbst it would it would be a struggle
for me to not say he because I'm looking
at a man you know and it's just it's
it's just instinctive so I just try and
avoid it because I know I'll make the
mistake and step on that landmine at
some point yes and then but then there's
also the people on the on the other side
who act as if they will only ever use
the pronouns that are congruent with
someone's biological sex and that's not
real either yes if you and I were to go
to dinner just to hang out and you got
there after me and I was already there
and you told the person at the front the
restaurant I'm here to see my friend and
you said the guy in the red shirt and
I'm wearing the red shirt but he
wouldn't take you to my table so you
know I mean it's just not approaching it
and being like practical about it it's
all very practical and people make it
out to be something that's not right
well that's a good point that is a good
point and I think like we were all
saying you know here we're all saying
she and Ed were the sound guys more
traditional so he was like she he didn't
know you know it's again he's not
hateful and even if we disagree with the
sort of modern transgender movement it
doesn't mean that the pronouns or
manifestation of hate it's just bizarre
and I think Bill Nye is the worst
but I'm glad to have a tiebreaker so
there you go there you go male to female
transgender na kijiye I thought it was
just a lesbian I thought it was lesbian
I mean it looks like it did it's really
really difficult and and it's it's it's
naughty at that point we're not even
making jokes about it were sitting we
were sitting there looking at the story
in the pitch meeting going I am confused
and we had about four or five people
come in my wife couldn't determine she's
like that's a man no wait that's I don't
know and that's different because it's
very clear obviously if you say you're
transgender like you said someone would
just say didn't know would say that
woman in the black dress someone like
this it would be that your guess is as
good as mine in the Nazi tank top yeah
which is why the authoritarian ISM
doesn't work because you can't expect
people to know what you're still
confused about that person what confused
yeah and the person looks very upset
okay Blair white we have to get going
great conversation people to find you
and support you
I'm youtube.com slash of we're white X
there's an e at the end of Blair
everyone forgets that and Twitter comm
is Miss Blair white and that's boiling
okay you have a patreon going on or
anything like that yeah I do
it's patreon.com slash we're white okay
I figured because right now with YouTube
everyone's being squeezed so it's and
you gotta get the coin yes you gotta get
the coin bitcoins for all the
Libertarians out there also she'll send
you a free joint there we go we just got
you the libertarian vote
Blair white at miss Blair white we'll be
back after this
Oh home body break with steven crowder
and not gay jerry some was a great time
to be active and enjoy some of your
favorite activities outside like riding
a bicycle even better it's a great time
at keeping new friend but most important
safety first ensuring that people are
wearing the right here to ensure a
pleasurable and injury-free experience
it's also paramount to learn the proper
safety handsome
for example this means i'm turning left
this means I'm turning right and most
importantly this means stop now that
we've taken the proper measures it's
time to stay safe have fun
[Music]
home body break with steven crowder
and not day jerry sponsored by mud club
[Music]
[Music]
request for that we return to the
drowning dance because a lot of
currently like to see us pantomiming
death death
thanks so much Dean Cain and Blaire
white I really enjoyed the conversations
nice folks hope we have them back a huge
week next week too we have a lot of
great guests we have Patrick Moore who
was one of the founders of Greenpeace
PhD in ecology and he says the entire
modern climate change movement is
bullcrap dad is interesting but he only
has a PhD in ecology so he's a denier
let's be clear on that he does not have
a bachelor's and mechanical and coke
brother checks are clean those cook for
their checks are clearing and we have a
few other people we have diamond and
silk we have diamond and silver in the
middle Simon and silk on Monday I'm
hoping that was just became huge I'm
like we have to have these ladies well
they have a publicist who's very much
like what do you want to have them on
for doughnuts oka very busy you're like
of course they are Christa that's
perfect if I were diamond and silk I
would be I would be the biggest princess
oral exclusive I'd be so exclusive
there's no way I would do this show No
so you know we were talked about this
earlier with you know you made the point
about Vox
yeah my point is you look at Fox and I
think Vox to the credit more than more
than most did you a very good job of
presenting their videos as being
straight down the middle
unbiased just effects and lo is there
editing I don't know if there's a voice
overs are their little cartoon graphics
that just pull on my heartstrings but
they do a good job and then you start
looking around you're like I know you
smell that yeah and then you start
looking through cross-referencing things
you're like oh there's all the
sleight-of-hand there's all the bull
crap it's everywhere yeah no it's true
by the way anyone on Vox who things that
we've misrepresented them you're welcome
to come on the show just like anyone at
Young Turks we we don't call anyone out
and not offer them recourse that's our
rule here yes so anyone anyone who we've
called out or I mean not everyone who
ever made a joke about like in the
opening monologue
Rob Schneider there is no fascist gigolo
Rob come out in you're a comedian but
still we don't call people out without
giving them recourse and here's why
they're a couple of things here
the best way to shine a light on
bullcrap like that is live debate live
conversation in real time anyone
including us anyone can misrepresent
what someone else is saying in a video
or in an article so for example we could
have just said hey Vox makes an
emotional argument and only shown that
portion when instead they could have
made a really valid constitutional plea
as to why there need to be sanctuary
cities they didn't really do that I
encourage you to go watch the videos
however I could easily lie to you that
way okay we've had people we've had
people do that all the time that people
do that what we say we've had people
we've seen people on the right do what
people on the left when we've seen it
going both ways we've seen people do it
with Dave Rubin I think many people do
it with Dave Rubin having me on the show
this guy you think everyone would just
love but turns out it just kind of
opposite reaction there's no most people
like them
most people like him but that people
down the middle think they're gonna make
a lot of friends often find themselves
making enemies on both sides as well
yeah that's true that's true well
someone like a layer right Larry White
probably has a lot of enemies and that's
why you know I wanted to be friendly
even though we disagree and and you can
tweet me at s Crowder baby tweet at Nike
cheered I do try to do a job here of not
changing my positions or values in the
face of someone who might make it
uncomfortable to express so so it would
be inconsistent of me to say like yeah
Blair I'm totally on board and
transgender no I still need to be clear
like listen I think you're a good person
but I also think that maybe a way to
assist people who suffer from gender
dysphoria is not the the sex change but
you know what
that's what Blair advocated sure so we
found common ground where we didn't even
expect to I thought that might have been
a pushback point again that's why the
live conversation is so important the
internet can allow anybody to be an
expert you can take your eight-year-old
son give him a week and say dissect this
monologue from Noam Chomsky and they
could make him look like an idiot so
please go watch the original Vox video
please go watch the original Young Turks
video that we talked about yesterday go
watch their original video go to their
original source and see if it's an
accurate representation ok go watch the
Bill Nye show we often believe in more
context not let's bring back up bring
drinks what for the Bill Nye show you
mean bring back oh bring back up you
should back up no
like bring something back knowledge
justice we should advocate that now you
should navigate that because people will
drink themselves to death it's true
probably already happening if they're
transgender it's a there's a good
there's a 41% chance it's statistically
accuracy oh this Simon got dark so
that's a big way to shine a light on it
but I encourage other people out there
too um it's not about the ones that you
see it's not about the MSNBC it's not
about the Young Turks it's not just
about the slate it's about the HuffPo
it's about the Vox it's about the Brian
Williams
it's about CNN if you watch this show
particularly for a mug club member and
you support the show daily you'll see
that usually were dissecting issues from
CNN usually we're dissecting issues from
from sources that people see is unbiased
Vox does a good job with that
as not gay Jarrod said those are the
ones you have to look out for and it's
really easy to be fooled so you Google
right now is changing their algorithms
to for example no longer allow or to
throttle any kind of fake news websites
so under that category
seems like opinion sites will be
included but under legitimate news will
be University newspapers yeah yeah so
Jigglypuff's who are editor-in-chief's
of newspapers the I'm a woman and you
better respect it by the way it even
doesn't even attend that campus really
that's what yeah that's what she said
what do we decide on I don't know I
still don't know I just don't still
gonna have nightmares every sound guy
says he so this is what's going to
happen with Google so you don't need to
worry about what you're finding that's
blatant you're gonna always coming from
other Jones but when you're searching on
a second Google's not really necessarily
showing you that deportations actually
lead to less illegal immigration Google
it may not be showing you that illegal
immigration comes with higher crime
Google may not be showing you that ice
just needs a 48-hour retainer period to
be able to come in and pick up illegal
immigrants Google may not be showing you
that illegal immigrants are not likely
to alert the local authorities regarding
domestic disturbances as it is Google
may not show it to you Vox may not show
it to you CNN certainly is not going to
show it to you they'll show you Russians
peeing on apparently plaster in front of
Donald ratings Dino's line
and they're still seen as legitimate
news sources PolitiFact is a great
example
PolitiFact said mostly true that that
illegal immigration is down no we know
it's absolutely true Snopes fact checked
us here's a good example one time Snoke
and I'm gonna get to the conclusion your
snow pwant Snopes Snopes one time fact
checked us about cologne we were talking
about after cologne there were leaflets
being passed out teaching migrants how
not to rape
we took actual pictures of the leaflets
now if you read the original article we
said that after cologne these leaflets
were being passed out they were being
circulated in in big vault in
significant numbers voluminous numbers
that was the original article now some
people tried to say hey they didn't just
print those those pamphlets were printed
long before Cologne Germany yes exactly
we never said they were printed right
now we talked about the circulation of
those pamphlets and Snopes tried to say
well if you look at this no this is this
is inaccurate because these pamphlets
were printed a long time ago but if you
read the original article that's what we
said just because you said because now
but now they're raping a lot so they're
they're making a comeback that don't
rape pamphlets just cuz you're right
your your your church evangelism tracts
were printing up in 1979 well using them
right well especially if we have an
indefinite amount in numbers and we pass
them out tenfold starting tomorrow yeah
be newsworthy
so Snopes says well actually were
printed a while ago well yes but Snopes
doesn't say and by the way they were
being recirculated in mammoth numbers
and passed out on the street after the
Cologne attacks why because Snopes I
don't even think address the Cologne
attacks maybe they printed too many
maybe they pretend to me it's just a
surplus here here Snopes on the back of
it it's telling you the wonders of
jehovah you don't know but the point is
smell sucks
PolitiFact people can do that easily
people can take anything out of context
and craft an argument against an
argument that you were never making and
vox does that a lot and they're really
good at it and so i want you this week
to we've always said this right set
HuffPost a lot said all of the sites
that you hate all of the people who you
don't like watch them listen to them
read them on a regular basis also try to
learn not to
them don't be angry about it but educate
yourself and be in the know even more
than that is I want you to have your
antenna up whenever you read something
that you think is not biased whenever
you see something we're gonna cache
water what is a sanctuary city you type
it into YouTube guess what's gonna be
the first thing that shows up time to be
this podcast this thing's been
demonetised by segment one okay by the
time jihadi bond this time it's on page
twelve Vox is going to be right up there
and again it starts with this as a
sanctuary city we can agree okay that's
accurate we're not Beyond agreeing on
facts and it uses that as a springboard
into speculation now there's also
nothing wrong with that if you're
straight forward that you're giving an
opinion or that it's speculation Vox
doesn't do that CNN doesn't do that
Chris Cuomo doesn't do that a lot of
people on the Left don't do that
something else that's important I won't
say that Vox is lying I won't say that
someone else is lying lying means that
you can prove a motive I just think
they're wrong now there are some people
who I will argue very rarely I really
simply this person is proactively lying
because you can go back and check an
inconsistency where they knew
information that they withheld so that's
something important too it doesn't
necessarily mean that these people are
lying it means that they are wrong and
again there's always confirmation bias
you are choosing to go along with the
narrative we do it to we trying to be
straightforward about that but what for
every every biased piece of reporting
everybody's piece of journalism this is
a comedy show but out there biased
pieces of journalism that you see for
every one that you do see there's 10 15
20 that you don't see the New York Times
up until recently did not think that
they were biased they genuinely didn't
think that they were biased only 7% of
reporters identifies Republican I'm sure
Walter Cronkite thought he actually was
the gold standard of journalism but he
said he couldn't be a journalist and be
a liberal I'm sure dan Rather maybe
didn't even know that people were
forging documents to try and indict Bush
maybe he didn't even know I'm sure a lot
of these people aren't aware that
they're super biased I know because I've
I've been in the halls at Fox News at
CNN in all of these places I've been on
these programs and a lot of the time
many of these people think well I'm
doing my job as a journalist and they
either make a judgment call to omit
something which is
pivitol or they don't even know that
it's relevant to be included so don't
atribute the motive but be aware that
for every one you spot get them for
every bottle cap you spot get the metal
detector be the creep with the zinc
oxide on your nose and scan across that
seashore because there are 20 more
lurking beneath the surface and one of
the most valuable tools that you can
have in your toolbox particularly as you
go into university right now or if
you're just someone who surfs the
Internet is being able to decipher the
left is trying to teach classes to
decipher fake news and what do they try
and teach you right now in school they
say well anything that's opinion is fake
news no no opinion can be real news
tainted with opinion opinion can be real
news and offering an opinion fake news
can be inaccurate news and you see that
a lot and you often don't know that
you're seeing it that's what really gets
my goat and I just bought one a nubian
one because they make great buttermilk I
love you guys see you next week Monday
with diamond and silk that'll be fun
[Music]